many of the founders of log now were
proponents of the new technology that we
now use as the Internet and we all
thought that fundamentally that the more
we connected people the better things
would be and I think we're finally
crossing a new threshold we're realizing
that actually connecting people with
totally no filters and there's no news
rooms doing fact-checking and any of
that we have crossed and and strangely a
new set of people are saying wow
actually this is we're crossing into the
people are yelling fire in the theater
line of the First Amendment right and so
that argument seems to have been the
fire in the theater argument always gets
made with every new technology and I'm
just curious as to what you think of
where we're at with this one and where
we may be at with the next ones whether
it's generative speech from from
computers and and if we just need to
spend our time getting used to
technologies and and or and kind of call
it truce during those times as we get
used to them or if we actually need to
change the law and say you can't yell
fire in the theatre yeah so that's a
really good and really complicated
question and in general I'd like to call
on the room to respond but I'd also I
want to say I think that there's a
couple things in there which is one of
the problems that you know I think a lot
of us are having with you know the one
of the problems that we're having are
the disillusionment we're having with
the internet right now right is it
didn't turn out as this kind of
Enlightenment project it's turned out to
be a hotbed of rumor and falsities and
things like that which has to do with
the specific ideas and content where I
would be interested in thinking about
the fire in a theater question is really
if we're thinking about when is the mode
of communication on the Internet
something that might cross over into
action or conduct and is that action or
conduct when might that action or
conduct be considered expression when is
it considered something that is just
brute action or whatever
and how we might think through that so
we can think through any examples where
some of this does seem to be more
material or to be somewhat different in
its mode of communication or in its form
that would be really wonderful and
useful and does anybody else have
anything to say because this is a thing
okay we have a question our question is
in the age of live streaming of events
and Facebook live streaming live
streaming on multiple different
platforms do you consider or would you
consider that to be protected speech if
so should it be regulated and if so who
should be in charge of regulating that
speech should it be the platforms
themselves should they be government
regulation mm-hmm
so this is kind of like a doctrine
question so I think there's some lawyers
in the room that could maybe field the
actual doctrine a little bit better is
this are you the lawyer in the room they
can feel the doctrine ha ha do you can
you answer but you answer a little bit
about it because you know are we gonna
recognize the difference between an
individual live streaming a murderer say
in Cleveland okay
versus a protestor live streaming police
brutality at Standing Rock yeah I mean I
think there are I think the public would
recognize that there's a difference in
those two mediums like most the content
of those two but then who would be who
should be responsible for determining
what the public has access to and how
and you know are we willing to are we
going to recognize that as speech and
then I mean there are so many questions
that kind of press we recognize that as
speech you know if we're gonna make some
kind of like blanket statement like all
live streaming is speech because it's
just merely you know the transmission
over a distance of something that I'm
saying or doing which I don't know that
we would do that's a question for the
lawyers then we're saying there can be
no rules no rules from the government
Facebook can implement its own regulate
Asians of that right if we if we're
saying this is all pure free speech
Facebook can have any kind of rule that
wants about that because that's not
covered by the First Amendment
but California can't create a law saying
you know any kind of live-streaming
should be subject to a five-second delay
or whatever kind of thing is that kind
of where you're going well I I'm putting
it out there for people to think of okay
because I think that there's definitely
a public push if you want to regulate
people's access because we don't like
the the platform's themselves don't want
to be seen as propagating violence
mm-hmm
but at the same time it's very it's a
very difficult and nuanced question
because who should be doing the judging
about what you know what the public sees
and what the public doesn't see and when
do platforms want to be speakers and
when do they want to be mere platforms
or conduits which is a really
interesting question like Facebook
doesn't want to be a speaker right or
Facebook doesn't want to take on that
kind of role there's another dimension
that actually between both these
comments that brings go that may be part
of the other discussion we're going from
a broadcast era into a narrowcast year
so the crowded theater may not be very
crowded mm-hmm may be a very insightful
kind of speech we actually there's a
there's a case right now about a
gentleman who's currently president who
incited people in his crowd without
public broadcasting so so you know it's
interesting because you talk about the
mass yeah and and we're now into the
Narrows in an interesting interesting
way yeah I mean following up on Xander's
question there's another thing which I
think has happened with the internet
maybe before that but very much with the
Internet and that is the anonymity of
speech it's one thing to say you don't
have freedom to say that if I don't know
who you are I can't stop that and so one
of the real sort of complex problems of
the Internet is that as anonymity real
or assumed seems to free people to do
things and say things they wouldn't
otherwise say and there's actually
almost no enforceability yeah and so you
could say well that's not allowed but
how do you stop it unless you try to
control the broadcast media who very
aggressively try to say hey we're just
the broadcast media we're just the pipe
yeah so there's an accountability angle
yeah and and right broadcasting is in
the media where that's happening
[Music]